il aura fallu plus de 154 ans une
autochtone accède à rideaux il
représente la reine au Canada
conscient de l'importance du moment mais
oui la x ligne 8 lors de la cérémonie
[Musique]
avec notamment cette lampe à l'huile
traditionnel en colique que les femmes
allumer pour s'éclairer et se chauffer
dans les froideur de l'Arctique mais pas
assez
il faut acheter la nouvelle gouverneur
général à une aussi ses priorités la
réconciliation évidemment l'éducation la
santé mentale mais aussi l'environnement
et
je suis certain que nous avons gagné une
leader qui verra ce que les changements
que nous constatant soit fait d'espoir
de justice qui souhaitent tourner la
page sur le mandat ou le de Julie
Payette a présenté mais comme une femme
capable de faire des pompes d'accord ça
pour moi
moins d'un mois plus de 1000 plaintes
ont été déposé au commissariat aux
langues officielles des cours de
français donc bientôt nous aurons de
francophones une francophile de plus par
minorée
[Musique]
par plusieurs
notamment par ton ami d'enfance
[Musique]
dans l'histoire
ici Radio-Canada Ottawa
[Musique]
c'est quand même une grande fierté pour
nous les femmes
comme je pourrais dire pense qu'elle
devienne notre menteur dans la forme de
leadership qu'on peut avoir et aussi
qu'on peut avoir une place nous en tant
que c'est première nation dans des
fautes aussi